[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hi, everyone.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: And
I'm Natalie Villalobos.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And we're here
at the Grace Hopper Celebration
of Women in Computing 2017.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
In Orlando, Florida.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's right.
And we're going to talk to some
people about their experience
here at the conference.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Awesome.
I'm really excited about it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Me too.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
We're sitting here
with Avni Shah, a VP of
Product Management at Google.
Hi, Avni.
AVNI SHAH: Hi.
Thanks for having me.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Thanks for being here.
So we're at Grace Hopper,
the Celebration of Women
in Computing, and you just had a
panel about product management,
and it was awesome.
I was hoping we
could share, like,
a little taste of
that with everybody
out there on the internets.
AVNI SHAH: Product management
is a unique position
because I think
it differs from--
it could differ
from the PM sitting
across the hall from you,
from the PM down the hall.
And I remember my first
few months at Google,
Google Groups was going
through this major redesign.
And the team was working all
weekend for this launch that
was coming up on Monday.
And it was Sunday
afternoon and the team
was looking pretty tired,
and the PM, Adrian,
in the afternoon at some point
left for about 45 minutes,
and he came back and he
had these like armloads
of sandwiches because
clearly the team hadn't
eaten in a really long time.
And so he's handing
out these sandwiches,
and I hear this
engineer at his desk
from behind me say, oh,
so that's what PMs do.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: They
go to Togo's or Subway.
AVNI SHAH: And get sandwiches.
And what stuck
with me then, which
was really interesting and I've
learned since is that, I mean,
clearly, we don't just
deliver sandwiches.
But PMs kind of have to
do whatever it takes.
Whether it's keeping
the team happy and fed,
or planning roadmaps,
or hiring people,
or setting a vision,
or kind of the more
typical PM-type things.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Basically doing
whatever you need to
do to be successful.
AVNI SHAH: Yep.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Tell us a little bit
about what it's like to
be here at the conference.
AVNI SHAH: It is incredible.
So last year was my first
year at Grace Hopper,
and I did not know
what to expect.
Like, just seeing the masses
of women here and how they--
just like this palpable
energy in the air
that's just kind of incredible.
And people speaking about
very, very different domains
of expertise.
So like there are panels
on artificial intelligence
and chip design.
It's just, it's kind
of all over the place.
And just seeing people
connecting with each other
and being able to learn and
having a community of people
that are here, it's just--
it's kind of amazing.
It's like nothing
I've ever seen.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Do you
think it's valuable for men
to be here?
And if so, why?
AVNI SHAH: Absolutely.
And I--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yes.
AVNI SHAH: It's great--
yes, thank you for being here.
[LAUGHTER]
AVNI SHAH: I think it's great.
I think it's great
on both sides.
I think on the one
side, it's great for men
to hear what women
go through and just
to, like, be a part
of the conversation.
Also, be able to maybe even
contribute in their own way.
For women, I think
it's really valuable
to see that they have
allies across the table.
If we're really going to
change the culture of how
women are seen in
computing, it kind of
has to be from everybody.
We can't do it from just us.
And so having the male
allies, as you said,
is pretty critical
to the journey.
So seeing, like, 1,000
men here, it just
reinforces that
the change is going
to happen from both sides.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: And
I think Grace Hopper
is going to continue to grow.
I think even though this
is our biggest year yet,
I think more, as more and
more women come into tech,
we're going to see more and
more women participating
in Grace Hopper.
And Grace Hopper's been
happening I think--
Anita Borg Institute has been
around for about, I think,
30 years, and I think Grace
Hopper has been around
for maybe a little bit less.
And so I think it
humbly started from 500.
So to go from 500 to,
like, almost 20,000,
and I feel like
we're just getting
started in a lot of ways,
feels really exciting
and is really invigorating, too.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: You know,
another thing that I've noticed
is I've heard you talk a lot
about visibility of women
in technology and how that's
so important for other women
to enter into technology
and to see the technology.
I think one of the
things that I've
realized at this
conference is it's also
really important for male allies
to be at a conference like this
and see just like the
enormous amount of women
leaders and people that we can
follow in technology as well.
And so that's been just
really exciting to go
to all these sessions
I'm super excited
about and to have it
be not always people
that just look like me.
And that's a little
bit of what it
was like to be here at the Grace
Hopper Celebration of Women
in Computing 2017.
Natalie, is there
anything else you'd
like to tell our
audience before we go?
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Definitely
come to Grace Hopper next year.
There's going to be even more
incredible women in computing.
And if you want to get more
involved in Women Techmakers,
go to WomenTechmakers.com and
join our membership community.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Thank you, Natalie.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: No problem.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: See
you all next time.
Thanks for tuning into
one of our developers
show segments from
somewhere in the world.
If you'd like to catch
some of our prior episodes,
check them out right over here.